oh man
the theme song is undefeated yo rod
Simba one of the 33% made it every guest
I've had in this chair has nodded their
head when the beat hits and the guest
today is just like the rest but he might
be faster than anyone I've had in the
studio
Ted freakin Ginn jr. good to see ya
What's Up boss man um so let me I'll
share this with you right away 2007 I'm
interning at the NFL Network in
California I worked there for eight
hours a day Adam Schefter still works
for NFL Network at night I'm a barback
at a club in Hermosa Beach California
and they let me work on one story and
the one story I worked on was the
connection between you and Troy Smith in
that draft you know you go nine Troy
goes like fifth six round and to see you
and I had to tell you like on the
podcast this is a weird moment for me
I've been following you your whole
career man thank you thank you year
thirteen you're 13 did you ever think
that we would get to the 13s a long time
in the NFL man but you know I've always
been a goal to get over ten years really
and then my next goal was to get to 15
and then let's try to get 18 so you know
I'm halfway between two of my goals so
right away you said I want longevity
oh yeah for sure you know the planners
came for a while man we're doing this
thing for a while you know I started off
as a mask out of my high school we what
do you mean you know I brung the team up
oh I'd love to do you know my father
always been there since 79 so you know
part of my deal was a waterboy slash
mascot you know I had my helmet had my
jersey I had my pants I sped it up you
know and I looked just like everybody
else I see that you're now training with
was it dr. Rieff not to read so went
viral a little bit with alvin kamara
doing some of the balance
test and Alvin's balances apparently
it's amazing like even for other NFL
athletes alvin kamara balance is pretty
special
yeah you know I'm trying to do some of
the things that he was doing and I'm
like how's he doing this you know but
it's challenging and I like it how
different is it now in terms of how NFL
players prepare their bodies - when you
first came in the NFL well you know when
you first came in there was a lot of
squats a lot of bench a lot of dumbbells
you know a lot of like hard lifting you
know now as you get a little older you
know you kind of get away from those
things a little bit and just work out
the little things it's a little muscles
that goes out first core muscles balance
all that shoulders wrists knees and they
just you know
then the things that go out first all
right so I do want to start off just
where you're from and your family
Glanville Ohio and your dad is like a
figurehead in this place and I see that
you had four guys on the Saints last
year that all went to your high school
you Marsha and Lattimore Hardy and then
who was the one I was missing when Shane
win and still though like this is so
rare for one area to produce this and a
lot of people give credit to your pops I
mean what what is he built there and
what did you witness well you know it
just is this like a diamond in a rough
you know we come from the inner city
Cleveland inner city you know it all was
established on from some guys before me
and then with me Dante Troy pure woods
as it's just a stepping stone for where
we come from you know just to have them
guys to be able to come to the New
Orleans Saints and I came in and kind of
came in together you know sure one year
two years with the Panthers they yeah so
it was like one year two year now we're
on our third and you know the guys
helped motivate me and sound crazy but
they do you know it's like a back and
forth type thing you know you plan with
one of your high school heroes or what
they call hood heroes you know and then
you plan with your little brothers you
know you just want them to be able to
see how this thing go you know and just
I rolled with you around
I oh you're a legitimate certified hood
hero at this point for sure like you can
feel it yeah I mean you know with my
father do what he does you know oh did I
see you given like turkeys and stuff
like you're doing everything in the
community I'm trying to do everything
you know just to keep our name a lot you
know it's not about me it's about him
you know for a guy to be around there
for almost 40 plus years you know almost
50 years you know coaching football you
know and track you know it's just it's
just a blessing and for his son to be
able to take over you know being an NFL
this long or just be able to have a name
behind him you know it's just a blessing
I saw it Oliver got drafted nine you
tweeted out hey man welcome to the
number nine spot and what's funny is ed
Oliver his main phrase is stay loyal to
the soil and that phrase I think goes
perfectly with you to like I look at
your Instagram and every other post is
you with friends from like 25 years ago
yeah you know you know I just I like to
say stay down sir you come up you know
you know so bill my gosh you know they
have a part of this you know as far as
my wife you know my best friends you
know my dad my mom you know it's a
collective thing you know and not to you
know recognize them would be wrong you
know not to shoot them out of me you
know we got from little brothers to gosh
my age two guys is older than me you
know and there's all about the respect
factor the getting family in Ohio's here
I'm curious like was your grandfather
involved too like how deep does this go
like how did your dad become the guy he
is well you know my father would see
Glanville also you know my mom would you
Gloomsville my sister with the Glanville
party Mike my whole family with you
Clerval between Glavine and show you
know that's kind of like my friends are
delivery guys and my best friends Brian
with the show you know wife went to show
you know and then that just does this
been our black and red thing you know
and uh my grandfather wasn't really
involved in the deal but I got my father
graduated in 74 he came back at 79
he'd been here ever since you know I
became the head coach in 97 he became
the head girls track coach in like 96
you know so you know when I came about
he moved to the boys track coach you
know and he'd been there ever since we
never wanted to stay title and football
or anything like that we just save lives
you know and track we won when I won
four with three back to back you know
for my for my time being there and then
he also won at least about two after
that three after that well guys my
faction you said we didn't win a state
championship we just save lives like
that's that's all that matters though
right that's the bigger picture yeah you
know is to take the take do you believe
that you've actually saved lives
oh yeah for sure I mean I'm one of them
you know coming from the inner city you
know know seeing the things that we're
seeing growing up and doing the things
that we that we come from you know and
just you know being able to to say that
you were diamond in the rough you know
like I said we got off the mood you know
and I wanted oh gosh I started getting
out the murder did once everybody else
saying I came and we could do this thing
you know now here come the marshal
enemies to Justin harsher the freight
carts you know don't forget about him
of course how can I just got big money
yeah and that's all it's about
you know is gosh doing better than me
you know doing a nice guy do better than
the next guy I also feel like though for
all these young guys they see how much
you keep giving back and then it's not
about putting pressure but it's a
guideline if it's a lighthouse you know
it's just like anything else I'm sure
you see some NFL players that get paid
and then separate for sure and it's it's
the ego that takes you know I just think
that uh with the marathon that we have
you know no yeah for sure that's a great
guy but uh with the marathon that we
have as far as you know who started it
the middle part of it and now we got
these guys like Frank court-martial
adamant justin Hardy you know Shane Wynn
you know it's a lot more Willie Henry
you know you know we got guys from there
too yeah we got guys around the league
you know and we just try to just you
know lead by example that's all you can
really do
so my dad coached me basketball good
portion of my life and sometimes it was
great you know sometimes you come off a
win you're in that ride home and you're
talking about that one play that worked
it's awesome sometimes I could not
[ __ ] stand it I didn't get enough
action now you're a little bit different
than me but was it ever tough to having
this role model that never wavered oh
yeah for sure you know you know football
my father was like the best guy ever you
know football you know you know we hung
a guy week we kicked it you know we
laugh we choked but then with track
season came around it was like the worst
I ever really you know I mean I'm Barry
my senior year you know I went in there
and Tony was too hard you know he liked
to grin at a table like just broken in
half it's too hard like this is what I
pay you to do this is why we do this you
know Wow and he broke the table in half
he was upset when you say that oh boo
table table
Wow and I was like [ __ ] you and I felt
like the guys I set me up you know
okay so everybody was telling you man
can you go talk to your pops practice is
too hard like you know I've said I'm
doing it you know I'm saying you're like
I'm fine I'm fine but then I'm trying
and now the tables not no nobody was
after that you know and then there you
know it kind of set a guideline of you
know when to speak up and when not to
you know and that's what kind of like
led me through the leak you know I don't
want to speak up learning when you know
you're rolling and accepting your role
you know yeah you know like I said my
pops is gonna be harder on you than
anybody else
well it was kind of like opposite really
you know cuz I knew what he wanted
you can lead without being led yeah so
it was just like you know a man we
better just do this man get it over with
you know that might be our best deal
there try to go around a corner and I do
it in there with all your trouble you're
like you know I'm saying it I mean it
was times where you know finally run and
it was always a track not really a
football football was like a leisure in
high school track was like the main
subject is football still fun oh yeah
for sure you know isn't that funny you
had work was track but football has
always been fun been fun you know I mean
the time but I put in a track made
football easy you
and with me always been a little guy you
know 170 or 180 you know you know I was
able to run around guys you know but in
track it was more like mental you were
the national champion in the 110 meter
hurdles there was a thought that you
might compete in the 2008 Olympics how
close were we to that actually to you
being a permanent track guy um I want to
say a permanent track guy but you know
it's just like what the guys are doing
it with with your major leagues and
footballs quarterbacks you know but uh I
was last fall you mean a baseball like
you know like a dual sport sport you
know but sometimes baseball might take
off before football football might take
off before a baseball but in my case it
was like you know I miss going to the
latest my one second you know did you
really buy one second I ran 46 five I
had to run 45 five to be a qualifier to
meet you out do you remember exact logo
never know I've heard a tape get junior
knows but you know uh this is kind of
ironic because I talked to Zach almost
twice a month
Wow you know for for all these years you
know that was my only loss that I had in
track it was - Zach local man we still
talk to this day you know and so you ran
your whole life my whole life and that's
the one L just don't want - what is it
like to walk into any room and go on the
fastest [ __ ] in this room you
know is a big state you know is it is a
big mistake you know you just got to
keep up with it you know and do the
proper things to make sure that you
still be the fastest guy in the room can
you tell like by somebody's body type if
they're fast or not yes what do I need
to look for for the future
you just size me up for a second I'm not
bad don't worry but you know it's all in
technique you know I really went on and
learned how to run you know it's a lot
of guys I heard as that's extremely fast
but without the special techniques in
the way you shape your hands and your
way you move your elbows and get your
knees up and things like that you know
that's what they lose it you know and it
might be that second or that sense for a
second you know I really learned tractor
and my father really like track you know
I'm saying yeah as much as he is a
football coach he's actually trying what
did he learn
from a book so this man picked up a book
and then pick up a book and then you
know just going out and seeing different
races you remember the books name no no
how to run by John Kubrick ha ha ha well
by taking senior yeah but um you know
he's to go out and you know like a
little meter stick that you see on the
road push out the little orange stuff
sure you know I mean he used to get that
and we should go to Edgewater Park as a
down in Cleveland and he made a heel out
of nothing you know he would take this
little thing and we'll gradually going
for new yards and then we were spread
out you know I mean we did a lot of
things that he can't do right now with a
lot of kids you know I had probably put
him under to jail you you were a part of
the era right before parents started
getting involved too much for saying
practices too hard yeah we're just part
of air like go with him you eat you with
him you stuck with him and I don't care
what he do to you
you know I'm saying it nowadays you
don't have that no nowadays if you push
a kid too hard you want to go down to
the state and say hey he pushed me too
hard or he yelled at me and all this
different stuff like that and then the
parents like to jump on board and did
you retract to the same year's ap for
sure I've been doing a piece as we was
14 15 I just looked I want to finish
more about your speed pro day you're out
of 437 this was coming off an injury in
the championship game where I think we
could all say Roy calm down you run a
437 you were timed as fast apparently at
Ohio State at 4 to 8 but you have told
people that you've ran a 4 to 2 yeah is
that the fastest that you've run yes
where what was that day I had came off
uh we was in Maryland DC I was in an
indoor track meet and then when we went
up to Penn State and it was cloudy no
hand time but you know they gave me
thinking like 4 to 5 or 4 to 6 but on
hand time I was 42 you know and I just
come from you know the day before you
know
less loose I had took a that's like
third in hurdles you know and and I
would just come start off basketball you
know yeah probably not that good but you
know I was more like a snow in Eric's oh
yeah you know Dunamis Sixers fan I must
say I'm I said too often sup i'ma play
defense you know fist fist yeah you know
and try to get it to the hot guy you
know that was my day when you run a 4-2
- how did the coaches at Penn State look
at you afterwards you know I mean it was
just like wow but you know from being
from Ohio
it was just like we're not getting this
guy yeah so at least they haven't the
scouting report for when they face you
yeah I'm a firm believer that I would
love NFL players to run the 40 every
year because I think like I think it's
crazy that Odell's listed for tee time
is 441 mm-hmm that's what it's gonna be
for the rest of his life
yeah and he's not a four foot one guy
just like you're probably like 437 like
I'm not a 437 yeah am I crazy
no you're not crazy but it's just you
know as you get older you know some guys
really lose it you know and they have
more football speeds and forties me you
know and that's why they just happy for
what they have at one time at one time
yeah because the other thing is as
people I've said this we should run the
40 with pads on do you agree with that
me you can have known people that were
faster than the pads went on all of a
sudden they weren't that fast anymore
yeah for sure you know I mean you attend
to lose I mean you have what 80 pounds
close to 60 to 80 pounds worth of weight
on you Dan
you know once you put a helmet shoulder
pads now you got to work thigh pads and
knee pads and hip pads and all this
stuff now you know it do take the
Templars or so off you know I'm sure all
right so I'm just going through your
whole history right now championship
game 2007 opening kickoff were taken at
92 yards to the house for sure did you
think they would actually kick it to you
you
when the ball is in the air can you take
everybody through what it's like to
return a kick like what is it like
mentally like what are you thinking when
the balls in the air or you check-in how
does that work well you know I was two
different ways you know you have kickoff
returning outputs
you know I will visually say that I see
more camera flashing than the ball you
know but uh you know you you know you
line yourself up you hoping that your
other ten guys is in the right spot you
know you just try to hit the hole you
know it looked different now that's a
kickoff return but back in the day you
know you had markers that you get to and
if you got past on markers you kind of
knew like I'm to the house like you know
all we kept hearing about this Florida
team being so fast and reggie nelson yes
all these guys just being a blazing fast
so in my head I'm like man first time I
tell you this is incredible Florida team
when you look at who they've put me in I
felt knocking everybody everybody yes
Cam Newton Tebow oh that's right he was
the back Chris Leak I mean you had I
can't even do the list there's like 30
guys remember Aaron Hernandez like
everybody was on that yeah I mean there
was babies at the time but the guys that
was on the field you know I read
McDonald it ya know pull but you know it
was just like my I just wanted to show
him my speed and once I did it kind of
like okay them eye-opener like man I do
it just ran past rest you know some was
no problem like you know I've said out
there happening you know I could really
say that Reggie dusty came over cuz he
just lost his mom right before that game
you know to cash or yeah you know I was
walking on the field and I'm originally
coming over I had my towel on my head
with crutches and everything he was just
like my keypad you know you're a real
special guy you know and I went in the
locker you know
you know it was just you know I just
wanted to show them guys cuz you hired
me Meyer sure know how ignorant he is
you know and you know he kicked that
thing off and I just wanted to just be
special and help me be nice pic so you
go there you get the touchdown and then
Roy Hall touring the celebration slides
in twisted an ankle was it I broke my
foot
I've missed a surgery but I but I'm
saying if that didn't happen what kind
of a show do you think you could have
put it was a restaurant game they was in
trouble you know I remember like
yesterday once I came out they double
gonzo yeah and then it sent the hands
and and at that point Troy couldn't do
anything because they just lowered the
box and everything was underneath and
you were the top popper yeah like you
were gonna but if you didn't get hurt
I was playing quarterback I was playing
halfback this was all the players all in
had AG information just as good to see
it you know trestle threshold idea was
to get this dude to in a field and show
him that he's one of the best players
that we ever had any position in any
position you know and so we were gonna
see you at quarter quarter in the
national championship October stone I
was throwing a ball and I was running
reverses like don't you that month of
practice was so much fun for you it was
it was it was so crazy you know you know
I like just going down there just you
know being in national championship one
of the biggest games of my life
all the paparazzi around there and media
and you know just being that guy you
know it kind of gave you the stage of
what the next level was gonna be you
know and there was also something about
the SEC always calling the big ten slow
and I mean you ran by them all and
that's what that's all it lasts I say
that like the whole week was just the
guy's fast we gotta do it is we gotta do
that like oh you're talking about the
fastest let's do it you know that's what
I just tried to show man
I'm so upset but what's funny is is like
I go and I look at your Instagram page
and you literally list yourself as hold
on look at your dad's
rampage and although you don't even you
don't even have a position named on your
Instagram page what do you call yourself
where I receiver specialist New Orleans
Saints receiver specialist we're 13
years in and we still don't know what
position you are isn't that crazy
you know I just like to go out I just
like to play football you know know your
role except your role and play it you
know like I tell guys all the time I've
been the number one I've been a number
two up a number three I've been in
number four
you know I bet a guy can't even get on
the field you know in my journey of
these 13 years you know and I accepted
every last one on for what it was worth
and every time I get another opportunity
I just show you who I am
is it hard to go and be a three or to go
and be like waiting for someone to go in
like how do you deal with that well you
know I saw a bunch of mental you know
you know when I was a number three you
know I had a guy like Brandon LaFell and
Steve Smith you know and them guys was
was was great for what they do you know
I mean Steve Smith was always great you
know I'm saying Brendon the field was
there for a while he knew his position
or his role solid numbers oh so he was a
solid number two so I always happened to
be the number three you know it's where
those wide receiver meeting rooms like
with Steve Smith it was great i sat
right next to him he called me Pookie
you know cuz you know I you know I just
did not a little bit you know so yeah
keep me up but once he realized that I
can play mmm and once he realized that I
had the ability to play in his in his
game you know he showed me so many
different tricks in trade or that I kind
of use now because what's funny is if a
guy like Steve Smith who I believe went
undrafted right or no did he know no
just eat Steve might have been like a
second round know I'm checking right now
Steve Smith wide receiver sorry I'm
gonna say he was drafted
third round seventy fourth overall but
you're a guy that goes top ten and
Steve's a chip on his shoulder kept a
guy and I bet you he normally hates top
ten guys because he's all about proving
himself
how did you guys work through that or
was it just he saw you make a play my my
first Runyon was Steve Schmidt was over
a foot massage yeah so I came in and I
sat at the front end they told me that I
was Steve Smith see over to the left and
I was like cool I'm gonna sit right here
like you know and I was using the foot
massage you know and I was you know
sitting there out you know you know I
got somebody in the room was to calling
him like two again afore using your foot
massage
it was his foot massager oh so uh one
day he come in he just looked at me say
huh I need a new foot massage I said
okay just like that yeah you know I said
went out getting the best foot massage
and I came back in handed it to him he
was like thank you like that super egg
yeah so but did a visually came to him
he said you know the reason why I don't
like other people putting a feet on my
stuff if I had staff okay so he broke it
down to me but you know it was the read
it was the respect that you have it was
some alpha dogs yeah so you know I know
you - oh gee in here you know I'm saying
and I did it without asking you like you
know I'm saying so it ain't no reason
for me to act all hard and cocky yeah I
just do what you ask me to do and now we
became best first best friends you know
I'm saying and all over a foot massage
foot massage I could have gotten really
bad get it went bad you could've been
like nope nope my feet are better than
many I mean I was like the second oldest
guy in the room at the time you know
might have been a third yeah you know so
it was like who are you talking to I
could have been like that but just out
of respect and when I know for my father
and you know the guys that come before
you in the guys that come after you sure
it's all about respect you know if you
get respect man it'd take you a long way
and that's what it did I feel like
there's respect built into even your
number you ever sure
tell me about 19 so you know first my
own life pick pretty close nine you know
my father were 19 and he worked for
Bernie with the Cleveland ties no I'm
not really my father was a
father plays sinner in high school and
then in semi-pro he played quarterback
and I remember I still have the jerseys
at home where you know he had the one
eye you know and it just is a special
number and in our in our in our family
right now
Wow so you went first around ninth pick
and you guys are like this is fate yeah
everyone else is what the [ __ ] Brady
quit and you guys are like we were
destined for this yeah you know you know
we just put the time in and once you put
the time and we got we got the blessing
out of it is there a phrase that your
dad says the most there's a lot of them
let's hear some of the best hits these
are 10 seniors great is this well you
know you know we had a thing like sweat
blood you know and that mean like you
know put all the time in when you with
your guys you're gonna sweat and you're
gonna bleed and sweat one heartbeat you
know you got to have one heartbeat to be
a team you know I mean is there so many
that you so really you just shake your
head your that's a classic yeah I mean
when we kick the guy off and telling you
you lost a team it definitely like you
know and and that's like something that
we just so what heals definitely it's
know like it's over but we'll see you
next next date oh oh really oh you're up
the team definitely put me back it's
more yeah you know I mean he was just a
special guy
especially not area sure and he's still
a special guy it was like I mean I
watched him maker I watched one guy
named Freddy Linux playing for
Cincinnati went to Ohio State for a
little bit he walked from 50 from Ayers
water to 55th how far is that that's
about 70 blocks damn you know I'm saying
it's like seven miles yeah and just just
just just little things that you know
just growing up and just seeing him do
you miss practice you might be sending
your front living room you come home
like how like how did you get here how
did you get here
you know under the window just to know
are we we just had so me like we have so
much of a family ordinate type deal yeah
when we was coming up that uh we got we
relied on each other but then in a sense
says we knew what we was doing how often
do you rely on him now a lot really you
know I'm still my dad of course I
probably get coached up more by him than
my own receiver coach that's awesome he
watched film warden party the Saints do
so you'll go over there and instead of
having a nice family dinner
he's got the clicker the cowboy yeah
going through your your feet positioning
versus slot versus outside high timing
you know you really don't know what's
going on but he's just a football coach
so he'll see so he can see it I mean he
could tell you well I think y'all lost
the game like right here sir you know
you know especially when I should
dropping a couple passes you know he's
deep like that's your fault like you
know can I talk about drop passes really
quick I had one of my bosses here say
that the most exciting play in sports is
a 50/50 Ted Ginn ball because you have
no idea what's gonna happen haha how
like I I think that you've made some of
the most exciting plays ever and there's
been some drops did that have happened
what what have what has people talked to
you about it what's your relationship
was like I always say I never led to in
a Fiona drop balls
I party led in a for the most exciting
drop ball not drop balls yeah and you
know is one deal that I you know take he
to know you know especially with the
coach and a half now who is your coach
now CJ okay Curtis Johnson and he's real
big about trot balls like I mean Drew's
gonna put it right on right on you you
know and it's kind of hard to drop a
passion from Drew you know but Cam
Newton that's an easy ball to drop know
and I really 11 Cleo Cleo wasn't now
Cleo was a good was a great quarterback
was he yes he was I only know that was
the first touchdown you ever caught was
Cleo lined up in London yeah bang a bang
eight and I didn't realize it was
international
- yeah I had the first score over there
you had the first score in London
history when a prong when he brought it
back
wow you're like George Washington Wow
yeah but but your relationship would
drop so like early on like compared to
now how do you view it like how do you
mentally bounce back from it but also
like how did you train then compared to
now well you know I was a DB I want to
put it on in my life you know I'm saying
and I always take that
x-play you know a DB give up a touchdown
but he still got to play DB mmm DB or
drop a pass he still got to play DB do
you think wide receivers are that good
to forget [ __ ] or a got to but who's
better you'd sounds like you think that
DBS are better forgetting plays I don't
think I wouldn't say that I just that's
the way I train a mountain mom mental
you know it's you know it's the next
play
always always taught that you know
especially in high school it's the next
play is there one ball you wish to get
out back to most just like - oh the one
the one against Indianapolis coach and I
was with the Miami Dolphins at the back
of the end zone
oh that was like your rookie year was it
and you had a huge game to his game like
11 catches but then there was like two
balls on the ends those two right there
I was don't know why I remember this
right now so those two those two I wish
I could get back what happened to me
through those places
one was I misjudged it I thought I was
you know going out of bounds but I still
have more Oh yards to go and then the
other one was just running through it
you know and where about your feet later
you know that's something that I learned
as I went offshore catch the ball first
and wear a bunch of feet later hmm
so that's one what was the other catch
oh it was those tools - damn so coach
that's 13 years ago Ted yeah still does
he ever come up in your head like cuz I
got benched after that I had a great
game who's your coach Tony Sparano
rest of his 20s Barreto I got pitched
and they only let me do specialty and I
came up here played two Jet's
and then you return one to the house two
of them I was thank yous back excuse me
in a minute and three seconds more fun
kick return punt return interception
return for a touchdown I will proudly
say
punt return Paul returns one what's to
kickoff returner and then interception
return third yeah so why is a punt
return more exciting for you than a kick
return because the judgment of it I got
to say bacteria which is why I kick it
to you worry about these Gunners and
then I worry about just pee pee in the
center and then after that I just
touchdown
so are you saying it's easier to do a
punt return or I feel like kick returns
are figured out on a Tuesday like the
structure of it all but a punt return
like if it goes left it's just all of
you you yeah I mean is more assigning to
me and some point returning it is
kickoff return especially not in this
age right now you really being a running
back back there you bring that ball out
you gotta try to just get up in here and
a man blocks and there's no more wedges
no and different things like that
there's no more for man where to see we
got a four-man wedge back in the day so
you know you got five you got about four
or five people trying hit this one wedge
like you know I'm saying it so all the
attention is right in this wedge and
then I can go here go there or I can
split do it yeah
punt returner is just all free fall man
what is your uh in your mind your
favorite or best punt return of all time
Eagles damn I hate you honey that was
like your rookie year 282 yards
who is the best punt returner of all
time that's partly Turner well you know
Devin Hester is one of my guys yeah you
know I like woody I used to do and I'm
always a charge will suffice
Metcalfe was up there Macau yeah Brian
wet haul Brian Mitchell DeAngelo Hall
Dante hall Dante hall incredible if we
get about him I mean he's one of the
guys that really came up with the and my
mind you know he started that
one-two-three deal where you go one two
three one two three and you hit it okay
you stretch out the defense a little bit
to create a lane on yourself
yeah it's kinda like passing around a
zone and basketball yeah then you hit
that middle guy thought hook shot
fastest guy in the NFL right now me Wow
didn't even I feel like most people tell
me Tyree kill yeah I mean I respect him
okay i gamers respect you know God could
have bought his had any juice out of
there you know and he gets up on you
really fast and he can run good routes
from time you know but uh me you you
don't even need to give any reasoning
you I've been doing it for a while you
outdoors I don't feel so if you ran a
four three seven at your pro day what do
you think you would run right now saying
how have you maintained that well you
know it's the way that you you eat mr.
Wade let you train you know well I'm
about to go on a diet can I hear like a
Ted Ginn dyno right now I just started
uh no no steak no no chicken oh you're
doing the Cam Newton you're gonna go
vegan on us yeah little fish vegan
status yes no I think you know you know
I set out a couple games last year I
think it has something to do with my
diet what were you eating everything
because I always been little like see
you've never had to worry I never had to
worry about it I always had like Peckham
pounds you like ya know now I'm getting
to the point where it's just like you
know this is you
I've been between 175 and 183 my whole
career well my whole life
I you know I was in between 210 and like
235 my whole life
wait so what are your biggest vices like
what are the foods that are gonna be the
hardest for you to stop eating a steak I
like a butterfly state well done we have
a debate my me and my girl we only
medium well hmm and a lot of the fan
base gets very upset because the world
is obsessed with medium rare steaks yeah
and I can't do it anymore I I can't eat
nothing that like slimy or like pleads
yeah I don't understand as healthy I
don't think it is I think it's actually
a snobby restaurant culture
where you go and they go medium-rare
this is how the chef prefers it like it
cooked by mob alright so some people
you've played with what's also crazy is
you've now been on to Super Bowl teams
mhm
everybody I think remembers the 2015
Panthers I don't think everyone
remembers you're on that 2011 49ers do
and which is one of the most talented
teams ever and then Beyonce knocks the
power out the Ravens beat you in the
Super Bowl if that power outage doesn't
happen to again we don't want that you
think so yeah we got no time to we warm
up get back right what were you guys
doing is that was happening
stretching well they was lose over there
like my herd good to power back home and
we we were ready to go like you know I'm
saying but uh you know it goes back to
like just knowing your role you know in
that Super Bowl I was a special team you
know I enjoyed being a special - sure
you know every time I touch the ball in
that in that bran you know I put us in
position to either get a feel or to
score every time yeah from the playoffs
started and for 49ers fans remember but
like you were replacing and I'm not
bringing it up to make fun of her but
like what was his name fumbled like the
year with cow cow Kyle Williams so you
were like the missing piece yeah like
the the stability on the special teams
Kaepernick was unbelievable yeah what
was it like to watch that ride with him
throughout that season I mean it was
great you know you know it's a little
controversy at the beginning about
between him Alex Smith you know things
like that but I come in out of smell for
just go ahead and just say hey you know
you take it over I'm gonna be a job next
year
so hey you know yeah and he did got me
some money too so good no it just it
just was it was a great run man you had
so many number-one players on that field
so tailed you know from the orphans to
the defense even it's even in lime and
so you know you know
and it was it was what it was you know
and we're enjoyed our time we had Randy
Moss in the building
wow you got Crabtree Mario Manningham me
Kyle Williams you know that room like
that was a great great funny room I tell
you they're any good Randy Moss stories
right over there a lot of them you know
I mean we all got in trouble because
they said that the receivers was
boycotting because I coaches the letters
out late and we couldn't warm up like
we're supposed to
we like man we do receivers like do we
got these constants fine like you know
we just can't go out there cold I read
one time and we went on our little break
I've never cried like man I won't go
back and Randy was like well we ain't
going back if any one of y'all go back
y'all got to deal with me he said no hot
tub and our coach came down and he
demanded us to get out we look alright
we talked it out he left he came back we
were still sitting there and then we're
gonna feel you know we got in trouble
whatever but you know that's was at a
time Randy eventually have to stand up
and say something nah it was just that's
what it was yeah you know I mean Randy
was over 18 at the time 17 18 years at a
time so you know no problems with Randy
for real did you learn anything from him
for sure a lot of things you know I mean
he wanted the best guys but and eye
coordination outside Oh deal right now
at Landry you know I can just stick his
hand up not even looking it's there you
know but you know it was a great guy man
he taught us with everything that he
knew Randy was more like a free fraud or
like you know if I'm running this post
and ain't no buy over there tow it over
there mm i'ma go get it these dudes came
rolling it or throw it up top this dude
can't jump with me I am that was more of
a will we learned from randy at that
time you know you know had a quarterback
IQ for sure oh that's all I've ever
heard I mean the fact that Bill
Belichick loved Randy Moss and they
would talk a lot that's because bill
only talks to people that get it yeah
and that's all I've ever heard by Randy
is that he could diagnose a defense so
quickly would you put could you ever
play for Harbaugh again yeah interesting
dude very was a Michigan guy yeah no I
saw so say it's gotta be tough now it's
not toughen ever lost to Michigan the
state really mm-hmm that robbery is so
[ __ ] great not a Michigan State not a
Michigan Eastern Michigan nobody I was
at your other Super Bowl Panthers
Broncos and it was one of the greatest
defensive performance as I never seen on
both sides both sides and yet people
don't realize I mean it was like under
300 yards of total offense like into the
fourth quarter very many only through a
after point it was Peyton Manning's
worst season of his career and yet he
run the Super Bowl but he made one or
two big throws uh I felt like cam had
you on one deep pass am i right yeah but
that Super Bowl was just you guys were
the fun team all year you lost what your
first game the 115 straight that year
had to be so much fun oh yeah well I
would just put it together you know we
got realized cameras as a guy that you
know Lovejoy you know he loves to be up
to a beat you know I learned how to
center of the stage you know and we gave
a toy you know when I was you know
losing every busy being at the time you
know that was hard I would open up the
offense then it gave was you guy was gay
was life you know and I hate that
happened to him but that's the onus
football you know but I just remember
you know when he did go out and you know
everybody was like what we don't do
because he had just came off a great
years you know I won't say about 1200
yards or something like that so like 65
if you like you got a lot to go and you
bring back to it you know you got Devin
Funchess Jericho got really come back
also know send and you have Philly brown
so you had like you had like a mixture
of big and tall you guys had in my mind
one of the perfect basketball teams yeah
like everybody had like Greg Olson it's
gonna be your like your power forward
and you're gonna be like your to address
yeah exactly like you know I said so
like I just remember that
you know it took a lot of work that
people didn't see you know what we're
dealing with guys that you kind of say
couldn't play you know and we had that
chip on our shoulder I'm sure you know
me and filly was your one in two and he
bring Devon energy three you know
excuse me Jericho Khatri was you know
the master mob and everything he could
play every Lee I need to play everything
you could putting my egg she could put
my Zeke put my F he's had some of the
best catches in the history of the NFL
and nobody ever talks about Jericho
gotcha I mean he's a great guy you know
on and off the field you know very
spiritual guy you know if you ever learn
anything about his background and you
understand why he's like that what's his
background just as far as you know his
family goes you know and you know you
know you know you just understand who he
really is and why you put that put that
time into would he'd ever football
biggest misconception about Cam Newton
it's off anybody can take on whole team
sometimes ain't so we're we're we're so
critical of quarterbacks I've also
believed that we're always more critical
about black quarterbacks compared to
anybody but cam sometimes I feel like I
don't know what game other people are
watching where it's like he drops back
and nothing's open and then he's gonna
try and create for a little bit and then
fire it like a missile 30 yards or even
this last season like playing with his
shoulder injury like here we are
criticizing his play whereas if somebody
else had a shoulder injury we'd be like
what a warrior like even trying like as
the seasons already lost still trying to
go out and do it I just I don't get it
sometimes you know it just is is two
criticisms that come with it with that
game with that position you know I mean
it's no different than Drew Brees in his
height you know I'm saying there's no
different than Tom Brady gonna run out
to pocket like is what comes with that
field you know and you know it just got
to be mindful for who they are you know
I'm saying Kim is a runner it's last
passing right
drew Brees is a setback thrower I mean
you know Tom Brady's a pocket guy like
you know yeah it's just what it is we
don't hear that about Russell he could
do it all he's standing privately he get
out to pocket he make plays on a run
Rodgers I miss my home's like you know I
said it's just uh you just gotta take
for that quarterback yes and you know
what else having a speculation of being
black a little bit you know it'd be kind
of hard
yeah they no different than laughter guy
you know James Wilson like he's great
yeah great guy like he can really throw
the football you can really play yeah
but all the stuff that happened off the
field
II get criticized Jameis Winston James
was just like what look man I owe this
show we talk a lot about how I think
some teams use the media during like
contract years to put out certain things
like mess up type of stuff like that but
I'm curious when did you realize like
what was your first experience of going
in and going this drew brees cat is
different maybe not even just like
playing football whether it's the weight
room or ever like when did you go oh he
like has leadership pumping through his
veins I think I read I played against
him for three years at Purdue no in
Carolina
oh sure Cesaro it was like you know
we'll be up you know we'd be a one time
we was a thirty-five sevens and then
next thing you know is 35 35 like you
know I said it's like wow
and he only losing you know certain
amount of time on the clock he just a
perfectionist and I watched him for many
years like I wonder what they offenses
like how is it it just seemed like guys
get open so much you know I've said and
then once I got there you know the duels
that they have with each other is
amazing
you know there's a lot shot Andrew it's
a duel you know I mean they both see the
same things at certain times you know
I'm saying
when once he the one might see it a
different than the other and he gonna
respect that and then it might be vice
versa he's gonna respect that you had
never seen anything I've never seen that
like that was an example where you're
like their connections wild well you
were sometimes you call the timeout and
it ain't just petitions we were we gonna
do like it like most coaches it's like
drew what do you see Shawn we'll do you
see let's come to a common ground and
then we'll walk never gonna run the best
play that we think we should run and you
guys got to feel so confident oh yeah
for sure I mean just knowing that you
know both won't put the time here like
like shot papers I paint say all the
time
you up just to be up I'm up working mmm
you know I'm saying he's a yeah I mean
he's one of the one of the greatest
coaches that really be with the players
like take a lot of player input yes
don't have a reason not to do you think
coaches don't because they're afraid
yeah sometimes yeah I mean but that's
the game like that's like LeBron James
and Luke yeah if you don't let LeBron
show you would he see then how we gonna
be great right you know I'm saying this
LeBron did come in and say hey man we
could we could come back down 3-1 let's
just do it like this do it like Tesla
right yeah the coach got to be able to
say okay let's do it sometimes you know
Sam because that's why they're great
that's why that guy's gonna be drew
Brees gonna be in the Hall of Fame
because he sits up and he studies from
6:00 in the morning to 12 and night that
crazy yeah and then Sean Payton was
gonna be a Hall of Fame coach because he
sit-ups at 6:00 in the morning to 4:30
at night you know I'm saying and like
for a place to have pump it's like they
got eight bunk beds 12 bunk beds like
you ain't got to go home whose ghost
airs get your cup hour and sleeps in the
bunk beds all the coaches know times you
know defense offense you know if you had
to stay over late you don't want to
drive home yeah
ghoster is that common from your
experience they're never seen before
really and so when you see coaches
sleeping at the facility how does that
impact the 53 like man we gotta be on
our stuff like you know I mean you know
I just I come from a coaching background
so I understand like when coach sees
something and he want to get it out
right like I remember you know the play
was like this guy's gonna walk down to
he's gonna do it watch he's gonna do it
we're gonna pump him no you know I said
and it happens and then you just be like
thank you Jesus I've got this coach to
understand game yeah you know I'm saying
I mean they make it more fun for you
I've been working more for the team cuz
I'm sure you've had coaches that said
he's gonna come down and we're gonna
pump him and you get the situation and
he's on the other side of the field
yes and then you I called the disease of
doubt it's that if you keep telling me
things are gonna happen and they don't
I'm not gonna believe you when they do
because I'm gonna think that's lucky
yeah it's just like a child
mmm you're right if you keep saying if
you do that again I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something and you never do it he's gonna
keep doing it I'm gonna get you that
bite in denied by percentage of the time
that Sean Payton tells you something it
happens I need 95 Wow 96 percent is
there any teams that you think Sean
can't figure out because I feel like he
could figure out almost anybody yeah
between them too they they gonna figure
it out today with nickname no I caught
him to a duel you just called the duo
duel
it's great duel and you know I just like
it because they believe and who they
believe it right no matter the name
right you know and we got this kid over
here he can play we're gonna figure out
really good and woody good he can do
best and we're gonna use him
I look at your team right now and I see
the chess pieces that are available I
see you scare in teams and you how are
you feeling health-wise right so you
scare in teams deep which I think was
missing last year
Michael Thomas can do anything you want
alvin kamara could do anything you want
Taysom Hill is becoming this guy that I
think sucks the soul out of people in
the fourth quarter it's third and three
and Drew Brees stands outside and he
gets the run you're like man they're
back up dude then I don't even know what
his position is because I mean and then
you had Jared Cook mm-hmm who I believe
is one of the biggest mismatches at
tight ends in the NFL I mean you guys
have to go out there on offense and go
who's gonna [ __ ] with us nobody yeah I
mean once you spread us out it's gonna
be hard yeah I know and that's one of
our best things it's prayer now you know
and you know when you got my tip I would
cooked
whoever else you want up in there you
know from whoever like it's gonna be
it's gonna be a good copy it's gonna be
a good you over that call yet sitting in
you oh yeah sure how long did it take
you
you're a coach's son so I'm sure you did
it quickly yeah probably took about two
weeks I'm sure you're tired of people
asking that question
I mean is one of the biggest
controversies in a long time and just
like I said when it happened we're gonna
rule out of it
do you and you got one we got one and it
is just something we have to live with
for the rest of our lives but you know
we have opportunity to do it again and
that's all there's about you know we
can't go into the next season thinking
that that car is gonna bless us got
going this season like man we're back in
ourselves together and let's play
football there's a whole new season it
was [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah for sure man
it's just I think that the ref to get
some type of penalty you know but other
than that you know everybody makes
mistakes
yeah no different than a drop ball or a
fumble or whatever it is the I mentioned
Brady Quinn earlier you you go ii my
receiver taking that draft and i went
back and looked this morning you are
undoubtedly the second best wide
receiver that came out of that draft
over dwayne bowe over
Sidney Rice only behind Calvin Johnson
and it's funny that the time is we just
experienced the girafft
we look at these mock drafts and if it
doesn't go according to the mock we
think that something went wrong yeah but
I look at yours now and go who had the
better career you were Brady Quinn is it
is it funny to like look back at it now
well you know because I don't be [ __ ]
weird getting booed well a young age I
begin boob for a long time I was a
coach's son so it was always he's not as
good as he saw say because his dad you
know I'm saying and so I made a name for
myself you know and I played like I
shall play with God great gods
you know Terry's Harley was the calling
Superman he was Ohio State you just
didn't pan out like we wanted to
I take winner touch a winner was a
Hitler before he was hitting her he was
everything he played quarterback he
could play tailback Wow tell you the
used to get officer MVP or the the
playing dealer he has six touchdowns
right you know I'm saying I mean he can
still hit you though like you know I'm
saying I mean I play with a lot of great
guys to make me become Who I am and I
seen a lot you know I seen guys like
Chris Charleston you know that played at
Toledo and it's at at one point you know
Shawn Shawn Williams you know one of the
best backs that come to Glen feel like
you know sand Terrace Hudson like I
marked my game at a lot of people like
you know I've said and ain't really from
the the big people that you see in the
arrow you know it's just the people to
come out of my area you know we always
had Talent no matter is basketball
football or trash so when they're booing
you who cares who cares I didn't care
i'ma coming I'm Aggie what I got I think
you even said afterwards you're like I
was surprised by it too what you know
for for for that for that to be a
quarterback driven point you know I'm
saying door we had just played Brady
Quinn it you know in the Fiesta Bowl and
he kind of took it to the wire yeah
great defense at that time at Ohio State
you know you know for me to be you
no up in the air with a guy like that
you know it was amazing that they was
like yeah we gonna take that guy
oh I'm sure do people come up to you and
try to race you on the street yeah
is it a lot no I just have a guy named
mace okay no not the rapper no well he's
a rapper but not the aggressor
he's our rapper in our in our in our
area and that was kind of like one of
the ways I kind of make money
here comes our hop that's incredible
he'll come down and you know he said I'm
get you today we put on $1 down and
let's do it you know what age is this
this is this 16 17 so 16 17 you were
open for business you wanted to race
let's go where would you guys race right
there on a football field so and for God
had been out of shape or not really out
of shape but didn't play sports you know
he wasn't that far off
so he'll he's gave me a race now now you
know I'm saying how much why did you
take off this guy by about 2 300 that's
all but I would feel like even now
people would come up to you if you were
out we should go Popo topo and I was
good night will you check it so you're
always down to do it I'm always down to
do it so cuz a lot of people refuse they
don't want to either get embarrassed or
they slip or they don't get there they
don't want to get hurt you're kind of
like I mean this is what I was born to
do
yeah I've been running from light pole
like poo my whole life so so I'm so I
could say this to people if you see Ted
get on the street he will race but you
need to have money is there a minimum
and you know minimal just one a mile
10,000 a better 10,000 are better yeah
why not this sounds like a really fun
thing can I be here can I be there Don
King come on with it all right
he is now open for business you think
you got it you don't got it taken
Junior's gonna go pole to pole against
any of you Buster's now 10,000 has
anyone ever taken you up on this no has
anyone my last argument was would uh
Chris Johnson he he came on our show and
believes that John Ross his 40 time was
not legitimate and that he should still
have the fastest
for tea time of all times how lucky yeah
that's all you you know we had that was
my last my first and last like big
argument was with him at a pool party in
Miami and we had joy reporter at Oh
it's young you had a Oh Joe you had like
you got some guys in there and I was
gonna say he's the fastest ever
but um you know that was the last time
that you know it got almost physical and
a lot of money got on the line Wow
but I don't can crystal run like that no
I mean you're still streamlined yeah
yeah he got like I told I said like I
thought I said Chris I haven't gained a
pound say man you play tailback yeah you
gotta be know you've got you know yeah
you put it back in a date oh there's no
forces guys but you know I'm saying he
always had the most respect for meto you
know saying because I gotta go out there
and run when he ran you know you've got
to have some power
incredible all right so then if we're
doing if you could pick four guys in the
end of including yourself
so three other guys that you're gonna
put in a heat who are the three that you
think you're gonna make it a race well
put Tyreke in there for sure you and
then two other guys like we put marques
Goodwin in there forty-niner are we yeah
yeah that man yeah Holcomb oh yeah
that's a good one
and I don't even know I'll probably say
John Brown from Cincinnati
now O'Dell mm-hmm mm-hmm
I just like who you say and know de Vere
bird okay where who is he on he play for
Arizona but he's with Carolina Byrd 18
and he can fly so I think we should just
have like the Ted Ginn speed Olympics
and we just because I I've reached a
point with the Pro Bowl that I'm done
with him yeah and it's it's it oh I get
to watch alvin kamara play defensive end
okay whatever I want to bring back the
quarterback challenge where they're
hitting targets and we're having
how far can Patrick mahomes throw it how
far can Josh Allen I want to see yeah
you could throw an 85 that's incredible
but then I like back in the day when it
was like Darryl Greene it was the
fastest man the NFL if all we're hurting
is people's pride come on man were
professional athletes I would love to
have that 40-yard I mean I know they got
worried about insurance but like come on
man that would be so much fun and I know
you're apparently confident enough in it
yeah for sure I mean because if you won
in your thirteenth year
legendary status a shoulder you know I
mean like what are they gonna say
nothing nothing
Sean Payton Drew Brees where should we
be with Dez Bryant right now like can he
come back and play this year that's not
up to me yeah you know but do you think
he still got it
yeah for sure I know he's coming off the
injury and all that stuff I don't think
he'd lost not a step like yeah you know
it's just weird that we haven't seen him
at all well you know who you guys tried
to yeah we gave him the opportunity you
know especially with me being out yeah
he came into the locker room he had his
head on straight
we know like he was gonna be a fit for
us mm-hmm you know and
you know I really don't know dance like
that
Oh God at the time that I you know spit
with him in the locker room in and out
you know just try to keep him a couple
corners on you know being the next guy
in here that you know playing with with
with the duel right you know would you
go out to look forward for when they
graduated to you and different things
like that too well and and you know you
know he seemed like he was gonna take
the role on ready pretty nice you know
you hear so much so good there's so much
bad stuff about the guy and you know it
that didn't come off to me no you know
he came in like I'm ready to go
you know I got the opportunity play with
play with some great guys you know you
know what with me having the opportunity
to come back right you know I'm saying
yeah like we I had Martellus Bennett
here last week I'm at a point now that
when I hear a team say that a player is
not a great guy there's a reason they're
saying that because it's not often the
case like typically your actions will
show me if you're good or not but if I
hear that you're a distraction whenever
like and I have never thought Dez was a
bad influence
I just thought he's trying to win yeah
he's passionate yeah and I'm tired of
that being deemed annoying to be able
like get out of here one thing we were
talked about earlier that I need to talk
about before I let you go you were a
defender you were the 2004 Defensive
Player of the Year in high school and
that's why I was asking about pick sixes
when you go to Ohio State did you ever
want to stay defense like how did you
decide to play off it so what happened
was you know I went to Ohio State and uh
you know that spring and you played corn
in your first year I played corner but I
didn't play corner I was labeled as the
corner so my first one Holly yes when
you line the quarterback running back
offers a line shortie lineman and then
either linebacker or corner safety right
right they put me back there and you
know I told you a jersey ran me over
like just Matt Johnson I never forget
his name
Ramius lock home you know they gotta
climb me back up John say dear Troy
there you know I'll get it this time
Curtis Terry dear they like we don't do
that like we run a hood like you row
like come on like what are you doing
yeah you know it was like you had to hit
up top that wasn't my forte
go low I go low so the next time he came
about took his ankles up mom
and I almost hurt him it was like we
don't hit like that in this drill wound
I was like well he'd already gave me
almost a concussion and my buddy that
happen again
yeah I'm gonna hit you like I supposed
to like that so in that timeframe you
know I wasn't big enough to sustain you
know at that time was a lot of power
running yeah how to sweep stuff like
that and with them having gamble right
before that that was kind of like big
enough to be out there and they still
you know wore him down a little bit then
coach Tressel was like now you know
putting at ain't reassuring right you
were like a five-star top country yeah
so I take reassuring
he's excellent on offense it would get
the ball in his hand that's just tonight
so as that went on like I was probably
like one on ones our party going for
offers from defense I have like two
slants and two bombs and can the white
yeah kind of like mess with me then on
defense I had like almost intercession
or PB you a good play you know I'm
saying so it was like he could still do
both you know I'm saying but we got a
build his body up to getting ready for
defense so I my first year I had my
first game of the season they gave me
ten players on offense because I know
the PlayBook because I was going back up
for if I was mainly and this is a room
but you had guys like Austin you bode
Dustin Fox Dante sure Tyler every you
have some guys over there that
it was good yeah they could handle it
yeah so tres put me over the fence and I
got into the groove that first game on
Newton play like that and then the next
week they gave me another ten players on
the new 20 plays yeah and then you take
on the NC State and he started me and I
never forget it judgments a wig look me
on a slant and threw it back that way
and I got a level right palm level and I
can't just sign on I was like tress
listen don't put me back out there until
I know the whole play like that and then
that's what we came out about three
weeks later we came up to fun watch it
was me he said Tony Oh God so Troy
Pittman man Roy Hall you know I'm saying
we just took it off we just took it over
Santonio Holmes telling all that catch
in the Superbowl
holy crap how strong is your OSU pride
insane yeah why not and now you're cool
with urban now that he's on your side um
I'm happy Utah
oh that's right he's gone now my peers
come how come hmm I just didn't like
some of the things that he did you know
I'm saying well you're super connected
to like the high school region so like
you're gonna know much more than
everybody else was there stuff that we
weren't seeing definitely you know and
you know I'm not saying that a kid from
my school should go to every year I'm
not saying that you know I'm saying but
this would come in and you see it's like
a look at him
and in my eyes he didn't do that mmm and
we you know I'm not saying that we might
either have the kid you know I said but
just give us a chance
plus we know how the state has to oh no
hi period
I mean look at all the guys that you
have in the NFL right now yeah it would
be stupid not to just take a look yeah
we got a diamond in the rough every year
down here you know I'm saying you just
gotta come and take a look I think I
gotta be for my high school it could
have been from this high school over
here that high school over here because
surely my figure
the way my father deals is you know he's
gonna help anybody and everybody around
that inner city to try to give him that
opportunity can delete yes sir is this
youth development what what exactly just
amendment so is uh I have three Pop
Warner teens okay and I have three au
teams so I have a fourth grade fifth
grade and that was tenth grade teen then
I have a a nine continue and another
like eleven ten teen you know so as far
as football went my first eighteen
nineteen went straight to Florida we
want it all Wow
you know I'm saying so that kind of like
put it on a pedestal like we care they
go again here's the kid family doing
this again the whole deal is to try to
get these kids at a young age and show
them the ropes you know I'm saying
because you have so much going on in the
inner city or that you know they get you
know pulled in every direction you know
I'm saying so I see that right now you
have to go get the kids ain't or not
when we was coming up you can catches
about 11 or 12 right now you know I'm
saying so we got to go a little bit down
online and get these guys you know I'm
saying that it's given the opportunities
that we had you know coming up that my
immediately had when I was coming up I
went to Florida every year you know I'm
saying and I wasn't even Pop Warner but
it was just something that my team did
you know I'm saying so and right now
they're marking kids from Pop Warner
through to start recruiting star
recruiters just look at that calf yeah
you know the Mambo
like you know all these guys was Pop
Warner legends correct right you know
I'm saying and then they went to college
did a thing in college and they're not
even made it with you how long have you
been doing gonna leave now so now we're
going on our third year so we reach a
point man where some of these kids make
it and they'll have been getting elite
athletes like that's gonna be crazy and
then it in is still keep my father's
legacy alive yes which I could tell is
so big to you yeah
is it because of his impact on you or is
it just like the name you want it going
like we're both used to impact it that
it has on me the impact that he was on a
lot of the
no matter if they made it or not you
know like I said I'm on high school
they're called Ginn Academy you know
I've been up and running for 13 years
since I've been and I feel well I the
CEO of it you know sort of like guys
like Justin Hardy yes are they graduated
from Ginn Academy were playing at
Glanville you know I'm saying yeah and
right now we have a 98.9% towel of
graduation rate is all boys that's
incredible but we don't get the
recognition like we supposed to why do
you think that is there's been an inner
city you know what's really interesting
about the inner city is growing up I was
more than the 80s so like 90s and stuff
I learned a lot about the inner cities
in New York and I learned a lot about
the inner cities in LA and there's a lot
of movies made about that and then as I
started getting older because everyone
thinks the Midwest is the Midwest right
but then like you know LeBron story
comes out I know Terry Rozier pretty
well Shaker Heights kind of guy and you
start hearing about places in Ohio and
you start hearing about places in
Michigan you know any and you begin to
realize like it's not just New York and
LA it's these other places in between
and you guys have created this
foundation in this environment and this
ecosystem really in Ohio of creating
successful young men then one thing I'm
shocked by is it sounds exhausting in
addition to being in the NFL and and I
see a lot of these guys like now I just
I need these three months I just want to
like take off it this sounds like your
other life it sounds like it's it's
consuming everything I don't even know
how you balance all this you know and
then there's another way like I have a
son that's eight I have a daughter I'm
at a twin state and I'm just trying to
make a way to where once they get hooked
to wherever they want to hook to they
already got a platform they're gonna
walk straight into you know I'm saying I
want to be able to hate my son said hey
Dad I want to play football I got two
tenders beginning right but now I gotta
have some people that can help me be
right - hmm oh you know I'm saying so
it's all about working around the
environment like everybody on my team
right now a place is a somebody's son I
played
me or a little bit older than me or you
know it might be a little younger than
me like but they all juniors and thirds
and yeah and and and you know it looked
like their mom was in a cheerleaders and
like you know I'm saying this yeah still
the same family base yeah that was when
I was coming up still just saying kids
like you know I'm saying so it's like if
I'll give them that platform that my
father gave for us then it's like we're
gonna lose them to the to the Catholic
schools they don't really just want to
bring him in for a talent and let him go
we don't care about they talent we're
just trying to make you use your best
talent to go to college then you get a
degree yes it is there a Ted Ginn the
third yes how old is he now
hey wow what's that like cuz I will
never have an Adam left go ii like we
don't do that I'm just like some people
like I heard LeBron say this on the shop
I don't want to call my son my name
because I don't want to put that
pressure on him but then I see taking
senior taking junior now taking the
third I feel like for you guys it's more
of a pride thing than a pressure thing
yeah for sure you know I mean my
father's put us put a certain boundary
out here that I could was able to walk
home I want to put the same bronzer on
so my son be able to walk home I hope
that he keep it going if not it's okay
you know yeah it's just set up it's just
like to George Washington's you know
whoever you know whoever they has to
boom boom the strong lineage it's just
what it is you know there was a lot of
things that you know I was able to
bypass or get through because of my name
mmm like what like just a street
sometimes really you know I'm saying you
know you got guys out there that
wouldn't let me do certain things
because of my name you have too much
potential you're not allowed to bang
with us or something like that okay you
can't stand on a corner up here bro you
got to go because when yo daddy come up
here you gonna kick my butt yo boy let's
do but everybody play yeah I'm saying
you know here take these two ladders
three lines and get on watch your way
yeah you know I'm saying and you don't
even realize that till later yeah you
don't really at the time we're like man
I'm just trying to hang out I'm just
trying to
yeah tryna be loud dad ruin all this fun
and it wasn't like like that it was just
that you know they had a bigger picture
because they went down the saying
guidelines but just fell to the streets
mmm you know Sam for they all mental
waves were they wanted to do like big
ones gonna let me do that yeah I
remember the most angry that I ever saw
my dad he was coaching a basketball game
one time and a ref made one of the worst
calls I've ever seen and I if he hears
us but you probably will I apologize but
he got right in the refs face and he
goes I'm gonna rip off your [ __ ] head
and [ __ ] in your [ __ ] thing and I
remember that I was the only one
laughing because I was like man I got a
ride home I was like wait if he get he
got ejected yeah I was like do I gotta
leave now too
like that's my ride hey what's the the
angriest you've ever seen pops or the
most emotional it's a whole waste track
always tracks something about track
track like it was always track like it
was it was Tom's like where if I didn't
run a certain time he'd take my car keys
and leave me over two bus tickets stop
or seven five soon and you'd actually
have to take the bus and my keys would
be like right on top of the other
and it was like you been like you been
like you know wow you know my senior
goes back to another one of my seniors
we had just got done running the
district no the regionals I just got
done running regionals he woke us up on
Sunday and say we're gonna practice this
the only day we can get the
hardest-working and I pops just PR yeah
like best record I did everything you
just asked me to do I'm tired I'm sick I
don't want to go there like two please
can you just give me a day yeah it got
me up and we had six heels on on that
imaginary line that he and we had
another six heels on these grass on
these crash heels and why time I got to
the grass heels I remember like
yesterday the first one I went up I
never came back down so another one of
my teammates come up Raymond smalls he
said daddy said you better come back
down here
I said telling him give me damn nother
guy came up he said you know if he come
up here you know what he gonna do - I
got to see how it's gonna happen like I
want to say another guy came over he
said just the last time you won't come
down here right now he said he gonna do
something to you like you know I'm
saying so then I rolled down like no
roll down you laid on your side and they
rolled down the hill and when I got out
I was losing like I that was a bad idea
and I looked at him I said I'll quit
after you just set your personal record
the day before then we go in the state's
next next week I quit and I went and got
in the car to my next-door neighbor miss
Tate and I'm gonna take me home like
that but I couldn't go nowhere cuz she
had to wait for everybody else to get
done so when I went home I tell my
mother I said my take me to the hospital
man I'm sick like I went to the hospital
I put it like had like a 103 fever did
you really yeah so that's a meal okay
man I told you I was sick man you know
like and then my mom said we went
upstairs here so stairs I called man
almost killed my boy today
Wow and so so I thought that was gonna
end with you getting punished really but
it was just you know that's just the
type of feedback we had to attract like
basket me football it was photo play
football you get you two or three
touchdowns and I see tomorrow you know
that all that [ __ ] led to who you are
today today yeah and we don't realize
that we were younger
no we think that our parents are [ __ ]
but in it it led it to more great guys
yeah he led us to the more shines to the
Justins - Ramos smalls - Robert Rhodes
yeah you know like I said really Henry
you know Frank Clark
how can people support you guys today
well you know we have a website coming
out our biggest thing right now is gonna
leap on Instagram okay
is it at get elite yeah okay GIM in yeah
and then you know you can always get it
off my website off my page yeah and then
we'll be blast in our
my way of saying a little bit - man it's
been nice to meet you man dude -
absolute pleasure Ted Ginn he believes
he's still the fastest player in the NFL
sure I've learned that I might have to
do something with your pops I might have
to have him put me through a workout and
then I'll just gonna roll down the hill
and go I quit the head great to meet you
bro good luck next season thank you let
the beat drop and hit him up on social
what is your social so take a game jr.
underscore 19 take it always rock in the
19 always a lot of saints fans got angry
at me last year cuz I would I would call
you guys out a lot and you've just made
it a lot harder haha so I appreciate you
who know doubt it's your problem
homies holler at you 33 percent y'all
are the [ __ ] I am in Vegas right now as
this comes out PGA Championships so keep
being awesome and I'll let you up later
flood his social tell him he's the
frickin man I'll talk to you guys later